my friends the first thing i want to say
is that we have this story from vogue
emily rajkowski talks about how she
essentially despised her own husband and
son
and it is some of the creepiest trash
i've ever seen from a woke cultist
this woman wow is it scary what she's
saying about her own kid
and the guy who gave her the kid but i
will say
listen filthy white guy if you like
emily rajkowski
mike more power to you i'm not a fan
she's made a career off of like whenever
some tragedy happens
she posts posts a nude and i'm like i
get it you know thank you
people like yeah sure great like people
like looking at a naked lady i get it
but i'm just like i'm i think it's kind
of
look if you want to be an instagram
model and she's been in movies though
was she in a bond film she's been in a
few movies i don't know look
i saw that rock i'm just saying video
and i was like she is so hot
every picture i see her she looks
miserable i'm like oh but listen listen
beautiful i'm trying to point out
i got no beef you like the lady by all
means that's your that's your thing for
me not my thing that's fine
i like the instagram models that aren't
shoving politics down my throat and
telling me they hate their white
husbands you know what i'm saying so
like
if you want if you want luck if you want
to get naked on instagram
and you want to you know you know post
racy photos and be really sexy and all
stuff i enjoy it i love it
uh the issue however is when you do it
when there's like a school shooting and
then you're like i i'm gonna get naked
maybe she didn't do that though i'm not
saying her i'm sorry i'm saying i'm just
giving like i'm being hyperbolic i'm not
saying she did that
i'm just pointing out not to stump for a
stupid hollywood you know to bring
attention to like a tragedy they'll get
naked and
be like look there are a few people that
this matters yeah yeah yeah exactly
yeah and they'll do really weird like
there's i don't even want to get in some
of the creepy things some of these
people do
but check us out from vogue emily
rajkowski on pregnancy and why she
doesn't want to reveal the gender of her
baby
all right well let's read the first like
let's read the first paragraph and then
i want to show you the craziest part
uh part of this she says when my she
says when my husband and i
tell friends i'm pregnant their first
question after congratulations is almost
always do you know
what you want we like to respond that we
won't know the gender until our child is
18.
they'll let us know then everyone laughs
at this
there is a truth to our line though one
that hints at possibilities
that are much more complex than whatever
genitalia our child might be born with
the truth that we ultimately have no
idea who rather than
what is growing inside my belly who will
this person be
what kind of person what kind of person
will we will we become parents to
how will they change our lives and who
we are is a wondrous and terrifying
concept
one that renders us both helpless and
humbled i just want to pause
your child becomes what you raise it to
be
when you place your child in certain
environments when you tell your child
certain things
they become like you they imitate you
how is it that we're in this place now
where people are like i'm gonna have a
kid and i have no idea what the kid will
end up thinking or believing i know why
so interesting how kids tend to have the
same religion as their parents
how did that happen magic i guess why do
you think lydia
it's because they're following the blank
slate theory they're following
constructivism and they think that
everyone is born with absolutely no
inclinations or tendencies and the
society around them shapes them to be
whatever you guys ready for this
interesting
here we go my friend who is the mother
to a three-year-old boy tells me that
she didn't think she cared about gender
until her doctor broke the news
that she was having a son she burst into
tears
in her office what a terrible thing and
then i continued to cry for a whole
month
she says matter-of-factly after a
difficult birth experience
she developed postpartum depression and
decided that she resented her husband
more than she'd ever imagined possible
so i'll clarify i was i misconstrued
what i read
earlier she's talking about somebody
else so it's not her oh
she told me that she particularly hated
and she made an actual
physical list that she kept in her
journal editing it daily
how peacefully he slept there is nothing
worse
than the undisturbed sleep of a white
man in a patriarchal world
she shakes her head it was hard to come
to terms with the fact that i was
bringing it another white man into the
world
but now i adore him and can't imagine it
any other way
she also eventually learned to love her
husband again the sound of his perfect
sleep next to her at night is now
tolerable oh just tolerable well that's
a that's so i'll clarify i was wrong i
i when i first read this paragraph i
mistakenly assumed it was coming from
emily herself she's telling a story
about somebody else i don't realize she
she had written this about the news will
do that
she's probably talking about herself
though well
she doesn't have a three-year-old friend
hold on hold on we're not done yet she
says despite my apprehensions about
having a boy when i call my best friend
to tell her i'm pregnant
we both immediately agree on our shared
instinct i'm carrying a boy
i'm picturing a dark-haired son my
friend tells me over facetime
i don't know why i can just see it i nod
and study the red fabric on of my couch
trying to imagine a baby boy's tiny body
lying next to my thigh
i thought she said she won't know the
gender of her son until it's 18.
i hate this she changes her tunes all of
this everyone has opinions on what to
expect from a boy or a girl boys develop
slower they're more work than girls as
toddlers but they love their mom so much
one friend tells me
girls mature faster but are so sensitive
it sounds like
she's talking about biological sex
differences it sounds like she wanted to
abort her baby because it was a boy
yep that sounds like she it sounds like
she at least considered it
like she's not talking about how
difficult girls are
she's saying that oh god a boy
man oh man let's just take a couple of
pills in here
she when she's writing about what people
say about boys and how they develop
she's critic
criticizing the idea of biological sex
differences she says
i don't necessarily fault anyone for
these generalizations a lot of our life
experiences are gendered
and it would be dishonest to try and
deny the reality of many of them
but i don't like that we force
gender-based preconceptions onto people
let alone babies
i want to be a parent who allows my
child to show themselves to me
and yet i realize that while i may hope
my child can determine their own place
in the world
they will no matter what be faced with
the undeniable constraints and
constructions of gender before they can
speak of hell even be born
i don't think it's the worst article in
the world to be equally honest i
disagree with her
but i can respect at least she
recognizes there are some legitimate
differences between boys and girls
the problem is there are stark
differences it is fair
when she points out a lot of the things
we tell to our kids are based on social
constructs this is true like you decide
to give a kid certain things
however boys still gravitate towards
certain things
spatial awareness type projects
construction building
and and young girls towards uh social
which is why they're like dolls because
like communication
i mean boys have action figures but they
they play with them differently
right
it's set them up is it possible
testosterone we know is tied to
aggression
prenatal testosterone is going to affect
the attitudes and desires of young boys
and not only that but for the most part
98
you know 0.3 percent of boys or girls
are going to gravitate towards
social things they see from boys and
girls did you guys have micro machines
hell yeah dude awesome yeah no so i mean
like
the video game on nes is actually really
good machines yeah we have like the
little tracks
and stuff the bullets are good too the
boats are good that's good
classic you should get these try it out
something i think it's a gold cart one
of those rare
like nes like link had a gold card or no
it was the ones that like were rounded
on the end
micro machines good nes game but boys
like things like
fast moving not i mean this is a gross
generalization
but this is ashamed when they give boys
blue and girls pink what's that all
about
this is what uh one of the things that
we we talked about uh
the other day i don't hate that i don't
hate questioning that kind of thing
blue and pink yeah i don't hate that
like a lot of parents now do yellow
right
i don't know or green yellow green the
issue is the idea that it's either
completely constructivism or completely
essentialism
it's mostly essential it's like it's
like mostly
people are uh you know boys are born and
have predispositions
this is um like nature versus nurture
right so like you're born with a nature
and then you're nurtured
around that genetic like there's there's
lateral and
um horizontal gene translations so like
you're born with genes but then your
genes can change
responsive to your environment as you
grow this is listen listen right
this is partly we talked about this but
the other day about how
and i think you might agree jeremy i'll
get your opinion on this thank you they
talk about
feminism but my argument has always been
that feminism
absolutely has disdain for femininity
because they're advocating for
females to adhere to traditional
masculine roles
yeah see what i mean what's the third
wave from feminism right right yeah
third wave of feminism
all feminism is misinjury no no listen
all feminism always has been like
women should be able to do that things
that men do it's it's not been
men should do the things that women do
like we mentioned this the other day
where's the narrative where it's like
men should be in the home with kids
there is a narrative that women should
be the ceos of big companies
there's yeah but the
traditionally feminine role and the
things that we often see
expressed by young girls are like shoved
aside and
and and we're told basically not to do
those things that's third wave feminism
no that's feminism in general the third
wave is to me feminism
first and second wave were basically
that men and women are equal that was
what i was talking about and then like
third wave was more like actually
there's not enough women in ceo
positions and
and you know the the women's soccer team
who lost to a 15 year old boys team
should be paid the same as the u.s men's
they should
yeah if they generate as much money they
should absolutely yeah right 100 percent
if they fill up a stadium i 100 they do
though
in the world cup right yeah that's it
though
no one gives a [ __ ] otherwise we we
talked about this before
we talked we talked about this before
that's still swearing
some people didn't agree but i was like
dude it's marketing if serena williams
can generate millions of dollars
in women's tennis she does though
absolutely yeah people and then
she makes more money than the male
tennis players almost all of them
so let's let's have that conversation
like how much does serena make compared
to how much some of these men make and
should they complain about it
men don't complain who says who's the
biggest male tennis player right now
is it federer come on he's a hundred
roger federer 100
yeah give me like a i don't know i don't
know exactly the only thing i know is
serena williams
man right me too she's a superstar yeah
oh what's the hot
i mean the traditionally attractive
blonde tradition
yes you don't know their names dude
[Music]
nana talova yeah yeah
yeah she was never very good at tennis
but she generated a lot of money because
she was
smoking hot interesting by traditional
standards
i don't think she was attracted but i
don't know dennis blair
martina oh yeah martinez i know um
what's her name
megan rappano the soccer player pink
haired feminist soccer player that
whines about gender
wage you got she was in the white house
this week tomorrow yeah you're talking
about wage gap stuff
yeah if it's true that they're selling
out stadiums and they're not saying
they're not they're not no they're not
selling jerseys
they're not because really when you look
at sports especially now in a
post couf era you're not even putting
butts in seats anymore
right you're selling jerseys you're
selling uh digital
pet
ian somebody just explained those to me
afterwards no no no no no no no i don't
want to get it done
non-fungible token yeah we're not right
now after the show
let's do a crypto show yeah i want to
like roast up i think we already did a
crypto show
i think we did yeah but yeah so my
argument is simple if they sell the
tickets then they should
negotiate better contracts i agree with
you and so they don't when they come out
and they're like this is sexism it's
like well dude
you negotiated the contract so negotiate
a different contract well haven't we won
this argument
it's not a no no you don't understand
there are people
in media who lie who are dumb and there
are dumb people who believe the lies
well yeah dumbness constantly no forever
but i mean like i'll always be
witness for the last 10 years it's been
like
my my dunk arm is sore because i've been
like it's like it's not a wage gap
my friends it's an earnings gap between
all men and all women right
not between a single man and they say
and you know if a man makes more money
than a woman for doing exactly the same
job
it's illegal and like
no nobody wants to hear that like show
me a man doing the same job as a woman
where the woman makes less
and i will agree who's who always says
that is that a reubenism
no um shapiro does that that's what uh
show me out show me a woman who who
makes less money than a man for doing
the same job and we will agree
but if you if you don't that does that
like you know like
it doesn't exist because it's illegal no
it exists
the issue is that it's based on contract
negotiations and this is why
on the whole
it's not just that it's that it's almost
like guys don't care
they're willing to take bigger risks
this is a fact that's called
testosterone it is
and so it means a guy sits down for a
job interview and he goes
on a hundred grand and he goes well we
can't afford to pay a hundred grand well
then you can't afford to have me can you
and they'll go okay can you do 95 or
i'll do 95. no one comes in and
they're more agreeable this is
scientific i'm not trying to
disagreeableness some women
and you can argue but you can argue
agreeableness as a better trade
argument but what happens is they go
into a job interview and they say
well um what's your offer and they'll
say eighty thousand will go
okay let me call my husband yeah they'll
say okay they'll say okay i have these
conversations with my female friends all
the time they're like
they're not paying me enough and i was
like what'd you ask for well they
offered you know 50 and i'm like
did you ask for 60 or 70 no and i'm like
okay
yeah well go ask for it well it's too
late now for the job
yeah but you're a misogynist tim here's
the thing there is
forty thousand people watching you are
about eighteen thousand subscribers
short
of one million subscribers it's getting
close well they're probably all
subscribers gonna be a golden
the golden youtube button or if you're
like me there's like 40
guys gotta subscribe right now yeah yeah
and leave a like on the video
all right well i don't know that has to
do with the conversation about women not
getting paid or anything but there are a
lot of women in the crowd i will pay you
women equally
if you leave a like jordan peterson yeah
peterson's clinical psychologist
a million subscribers tonight okay
uh jordan peterson has posted clinical
data about
agreeableness which is a personality
trait i feel so bad yeah he got kind of
raked for it
but women tend to be more agreeable on
average and that's because of their
their communication skills in the family
it's it's about not you know
shutting people down but men are it's
way easier for on average men to be less
agreeable which is why contract
negotiations men are stupider
it's the greater male variability
hypothesis that
women tend to cluster around the the
center of the bell curve
and men have a wider bell curve meaning
you are more likely to encounter a
really dumb man you're also more likely
to encounter a really smart oh that's it
every
day so it's i thought about this too
because there's a trope about you know
women saying god men are so dumb
and like they're not wrong because men
are also supposed to because if you have
100 men
and 100 women you're going to have 10
dumb women
80 average women and 10 smart women if
you have 100 men
you're gonna have four you know 20
really dumb man you could have something
60 average and 20 and the stupidest of
humans will tend to be men yes and the
smartest humans will tend to be men
yes so here's what happens if you have
100 men and 100 women
and you've got 20 male geniuses and 10
female geniuses
you now have 2 2 1 competing for the
same job those aren't actual numbers
this is probably very different
that'd be if everybody in the world
world was applying for one job and let's
say let's say yeah
there's there's five positions there's
30 people
and 20 of them are guys there's a very
high probability it will be all five
guys yep yeah
all five that's how you end up with all
the males because you've got
if you reached your hand into a hat okay
let's let's just do regular
a sexism hat not a regular probability
say we're to do blind hiring
so we have the smartest women and the
smartest men in this hat we only have
five you pull one
two three four five very strong
likelihood
all dudes all right if you take into
account that the extremes tend to be
male that you and you're only trying to
fill one role which is the ceo of google
you look for the smartest human which
tends to be not it's not his case
it's it's just something but that's
intelligence is a weird word too
and the more people that exist the
bigger the gap
becomes because if it's two to if it's
two if it's two to one
you're going to have one job the ceo of
google and you're gonna have
two million guys and one million women
two
million from each so what they do then
is you get these equity constructivist
people who are like well then you have
to choose the women
and it's like that's that doesn't make
sense either well that's how it is
though you're pulling them out
congratulations you got a guy so in my
day job i have
uh at least one fortune 500 company that
works for me and i've seen this
garbage on the into on the internals of
corporate culture
and it's real it's not we need to hire
the best person for the job not at the
executive level
at the sales level at any job that is
like won't go broke
yeah dude not at the not at the level
where performance matters but
we're the level where people see
performance always matters man
it does not especially in the military
if you're the military that's i don't
want to
rear-end the conversation because that's
what i keep thinking about let's say you
have 100 employees and 80 do the actual
bird house manufacturing
then you've got 10. they're using
mcginty screws probably to those let's
say let's say let's say you've got 80
people actually doing the work
you got 10 people you got 15 people in
an administrative and managerial role
and then five executives
you get you you put in one bed executive
and they start just doing weird things
even if they're not involved in the
day-to-day process eventually an email
pops up where they screen bigotry
disrupt operations slug up the time and
then everything starts getting jammed up
and they will perform
worse than a company that doesn't have
that you know weirdo person
yeah but that doesn't prevent them from
getting the job what i'm saying is
that there are that diversity quotas are
freaking real
they're real and if if they can't fill
it in an existing world they create them
and that's why you end up with diversity
czar
or whatever the hell it is yeah chief
diversity officer yeah like
that's what it i mean it's real like i'm
not i mean that is you know it shouldn't
be controversial to say when they create
the position called like
the office of diversity inclusivity by
the way it's
never a man that has that job when they
create these positions
they're basically akin to creating the
chinese communist party offices
in chinese businesses they want the they
want their church
in every company and they're winning
they're getting these things
imagine every company had to have a
christian church
and and and chaplin to administer
administer the the
proper christian ideology to what the
business does
that's what they're doing with the
diversity inclusivity inclusivity and
equity
stuff do you know how these job
negotiations go it's like the mob
or it's like getting when you're black
and you get pulled over in a small town
like oh your tail lights out like oh
that's a nice business you have there
sure would be a shame if something
happened to it you should probably kiss
your baby
yeah you should probably hire me i have
a 150
000 in college debt from colombia and i
have a degree in gender
studies you should probably hire me as a
diversity
if you look at every major video game
company riot games blizzard
they all have these roles and they're
all completely useless
and they all make huge money it's like a
it's like a mafia thanks for checking
out this clip from the tim cast irl
podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you